[Music]
gotta welcome along to this
extraordinary meeting of the performance
policy and partnerships uh committee
uh
welcome those joining us on line
uh and via zoom
we have uh apology and apology from
councillor kit
i and on zoom
uh councillor rabbit councillor carter
we did have mrs cooper she's obviously
popped off to catch her flight that's
fine
i've done it again sorry nobby
councillor clark
it starts with a c my sincere apology
i like to pass that on to her later on
this evening
before that it'll be cause for a bottle
of wine
um i'll just take this opportunity to
note that uh councillor abbott has said
he is feeling unwell he is he was
obviously here for um
uh the the submissions when they were
being made but um he will sit in and
listen to the deliberation but he said
he is not going to be voting he doesn't
feel comfortable with that so thank you
for uh
for letting me know about that
lindsay appreciate it
um
oh well i haven't uh put that motion so
i've got the apologies and zoom
attendees i'll move seconded
councillor crackit
last hand i saw go up
any discussion i put the motion all in
favor
against
carried
uh we need to
move that we receive the
minor late item and a major late item
i will do the minor late item first
which is the conflict of interest advice
does somebody want to move that we
accept this
counselor scout councillor lewis
put that all in favor
aye against carried and the major late
item
which is the proposed regional
submission for the national adaptation
plan consultation it's going to want to
move receive that council emerson and
councillor crackit
discussion put the motion all in favor
aye aye against
kerry
so we'll get to the
minor
late item for a start
which is the
conflict of interest advice
um
you've had a chance to read through
the report as a part of the
agenda
it deals with
councillor clark
having been a submitter on behalf behalf
of the
rate payers advocacy group
there is
no clear authority for me as chair
to rule in any direction
and i don't believe that i have
a right to say that counselor clark
cannot participate in discussions there
are some pretty clear guidelines and i
guess
by way of of setting a context and
summarizing
some of what is in uh in the report
um
there are two things around conflicts
the
the uh an actual conflict of interest
and in our cases it is seldom a
pecuniary conflict
and in this instance it's not a
pecuniary conflict
um or the perception of a conflict of
interest
which is
is a higher threshold
but it's also a subjective one
and one that we've had tested before in
in previous meetings
at uh at
previous councils or this council
previously to this term
and
it's around the ability of
an elected member to
maintain an open mind
so
counselor clark
can
i ask for you some clarification on the
way you
plan on proceeding through the
discussions
thank you chair um a couple of things um
the issue of perception is around the
community's ability to know that you've
had an open mind and listen to the
submission
and haven't come with a predetermined
position
the issue of predetermination can be um
could be uh leaving it a lobby that many
members who um prior to physical
submissions can make decisions about
what our rate increase still should not
be
i've kept an open mind
i've only advocated or our group has
only advocated for the four percent that
was in the long term plan we openly
acknowledge the information put forward
by the staff
which is that they need another 3.15 and
we don't we don't have any opposition to
that that's the needs of the
organization so we're quite open about
that
and i'm still open and you'll be aware
of i've written a document to all all my
colleagues about what levers we use to
bridge the gap between the four percent
and the 7.15 and i've got quite an open
mind on that because there are many
levers available to us
so i don't come with any
predetermination
and so i think um
when you consider the risk to counsel of
somebody saying he had a predetermined
position
i don't think anybody will be off to the
high court on that issue
if
they consider that i'm actually asking
for the rates to be lower than what the
recommendations are in the report
thank you councillor for those who are
playing catch-up we are on tab nine
which is the the conflict advice
councillor crackit
um
thank you um
counselor ludlow um
my questioning is a bit around the
possible consequences of that and that
given if um
councillor clark
has said he would intend to participate
in deliberations
and
also vote
if a member of public
perceived that he did not have an open
mind in going into this and
wanted to follow that up and that
potentially opens us up for judicial
review
given that these decisions that we're
making now are really critical and that
this is going to determine our work plan
for the next year
is that judicial review going to stop or
halt or mean that we can't actually
conduct the business
i guess in trying to answer that
it would depend on the outcome of the
deliberations which is really the
process we're going through today so
today we are deliberating on the
submissions that we heard in chamber a
couple of weeks ago
from here we shape
the recommendations back to staff who
will present a report that will come
back to this committee on the 14th of
june
from there we will finalize the amount
that we plan on recommending to council
to strike as the rate for the 2022-23
year
and that point on june 14th is really
council's last chance to make
any last minute changes
it would be
unwise at that point to be making
substantial changes
because it would place an unfair burden
on the staff
and when we get to the 28th
striking of the rate at full council
that is it's really procedural um and
and we can't make any changes at that
point
so i guess your condition your question
around a judicial review depends on the
outcome and and i guess we don't know
until we get to the end of discussions
today and then ultimately where the
committee makes a recommendation to the
council on june 14th
um
i don't want to predetermine an outcome
but if if there is a dramatic swing from
where we may have been trending and and
our minds all our minds are open
that is a possibility but it's a
possibility that exists with the many of
the decisions that we make
um and thank you um councillor i'm in no
way seeking to um offend or slight
councillor clark and his um
and his decision of what he intends to
do i was merely just trying to
i guess
understand what kind of impact it would
have on
us continuing
well look the report from from mr morris
acknowledges the fact that one of the
potential outcomes is a judicial review
and that can apply to many things that
we go through so i mean it's reasonable
that you ask a question hopefully that
provides
a context
councillor pottinger
thank you chair look i would uh support
councillor clark uh's own decision
he's given a thought
and for his
participation i've looked at all the
rules and it is purely
up to the individual i love
the latin bit including nemo
that's quite a lyrics having done latin
at school i never thought it would come
in handy
um but i like to bring the com put it in
perspective and bring this committee's
attention to
a meeting i cheered on the 15th of march
and that was
deciding
which option was for the museum was
going to go out to public consultation
whether it was option 2 or option 3.
now i look back at the minutes from that
and there was no declarations of
interest
for that meeting yet
yourself chair as chair of smag
moved an amendment from the staff's
recommendation seconded by ms cook
who is also a member of smag and
the reimagination
uh committee
uh they moved and seconded the motion
um and then that was debated and since
that
that was uh voted on in the affirmative
also during the meeting we had council
of sopa council romansen who were
who are members or were members i'm not
sure if smack still exists there were no
declarations there and to me
the southern museum and art gallery
would have had great interest
in the outcome of the museum so
you know and i
i look back on that and i wasn't going
to say anything because it's up to the
individual so i respect each
individual's choice but i'd just like to
remind the committee
that if you look back on a judicial
review
and you look back to the actual what was
put in front of the public for their
choice for option two or option three
which has a huge sway i believe
against what the staff recommended
then you could probably say was that a
conflict we staff they should have gone
with the staff's option first and then
at the right time during
these deliberations
decide
then option two was better because the
public wanted it so i'm just making this
committee very aware of that thanks
councillor i i guess it's one of those
interesting points where it comes down
to the terminology and the difference
between a conflict and an interest
it is absolutely true that the four
people you've
noted including myself
members were slashed one of them still
is members of the smack trust board
three of those people are council
appointees to it so uh uh they're
wearing a council hat so we have an
interest
a non-pecuniary one but i don't believe
in that instance uh a conflict but
you're right it does it is subjective it
comes down to
uh the counselor at the time i recall
during the sde debate you made a
declaration yourself about having an
open mind before taking part in in the
debate so
you know how do you how do you prove
that somebody doesn't
and that that applies to any of us there
could be people who have not made any
declarations i mean is it a conflict
that
sorry bex doesn't mean to be a
backhander but you know your husband was
a submitter
um
is that a conflict
not necessarily because you know how do
we know that there was any discussion
between i wouldn't know if there was
something coming from es what was going
on simply because my wife's a counselor
so it comes down to the individual
at the time
are there any other questions or
comments
reverend cook
um so i want to comment
because
um i stood aside from voting on the
stormwater
application because an organisation of
which i am the chair
was a submitter
we had no pecuniary gain to be made from
that
but because the perception
um
and and slightly following on from what
happened about the 15th of march meeting
as well at which it was drawn to my
attention that there was a perception
that i was
appointed by council to um
well there was something about how i got
onto the imagining group um as it turned
out it wasn't quite
quite correct either but that's not the
point the perception is what the issue
is
and whilst we all
at times
wear more than one hat when we're
sitting at this table it's to be really
mindful
how it can be seen by other people
i'm
a little bit uncomfortable
with
a counselor submitting in person
again to this and then deliberating i
think that's slightly different than an
organisation
where they submit
and you're not seen as part of the
organisation necessarily you're not the
front of the organisation
but that's my personal thing and i have
to work my way through that but in in
terms of how this perception of conflict
and how we're seen by the public i think
we do have to be mindful and it does it
does slightly alarm me the position that
we find ourselves in at the moment but
i will go with how the majority goes
because i think that is democratic
thanks i'm not sure it's a majority
decision because the only decision in
front of us is really to receive the
report
um
which i'll do in a moment and then call
a brief adjournment whilst we deal with
the technical issue
but councillor clark has has made his
declaration and um
i respect us and right as an individual
to do that
so i will move to the point of order
sorry to you just that to to make it
quite clear to all uh committee that
section 20.8 of standing orders says
that neither the chair nor the committee
can rule on a non-financial conflict of
interest correct
councillor clark sorry you had your hand
up
thank you chair um
just to help um the audis that some of
my colleagues have
um
there are two meetings here and you
quite rightly said that today's meeting
is an information sharing meeting and i
think as an elected member i have a
right to put forward and to ask
questions of staff who present
um the decision making on this is
actually not until the 14th of june
so the reports today all say
the recommendations are all receive the
report and then note note nope note all
the way down so they're not recommending
one thing or the other they're just
giving us background information that
will lead us
to some further deliberations and
on to some decision making on the 14th
of june
and i want felt that my uh
majority of my colleagues were
uncomfortable about the 14th of june and
i would consider whether i participated
at that stage i guess
right
councils i think that brings that matter
to a conclusion uh the recommendation is
that the committee receives the report
uh and i think we need to make note of
it so i'll move if there's a second
i'll second that council of sopa put the
motion all in favor
against carried i'm not going to call a
brief adjournment whilst we deal with
some technical issues with the live
stream and then we will resume with the
agenda take five minutes
you